[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans audition
publique sur les chaînes parlementaires
lcp et public sénat comme un changement
d'ambiance ces derniers jours le
président macron s'adresse aux français
demain soir 20 heures comme il ne
l'avait pas fait depuis le 12 juillet
dernier du coup record de vaccination
pour la 3è dos ça rappelle quelque chose
mais le président parlerai aussi demain
pouvoir d'achat réforme situation
internationale est il tenté de vouloir
reprendre la main sur un débat politique
très présidentiel un peu décousu
insaisissable bonsoir monde bonsoir
lamartine merci beaucoup d'être avec
vous ce soir donc pour une heure une
heure d'émission vous êtes un candidat à
l'elysée vous parler haut et fort vous
avez un discours j'allais dire
intéressant c'est pas un jugement de
valeur de ma part c'est que souvent
c'est vrai vous posez des débats et des
débats de fond hier vous êtes allez
peut-être un peu fort on va revenir tout
de suite sur cette proposition qui a
créé un tollé notamment à gauche et des
saluts un extrême droite propositions
formulées dans le grand jury lci rtl le
figaro je le rappelle si vous voulez
bien quelques instants vous avez dit
texto je me suis décidé à taper au
portefeuille
vous parliez des expulsions des cent
mille personnes clandestine faisant
l'objet d'une obligation de quitter le
territoire vous regretter qu'elle ne
soit pas exécutée et vous disiez il faut
bloquer les transferts tant que pas
d'accord quand il n'y a pas d'accord de
coopération nous bloquons au site nous
bloquons tous les transferts ou si
longtemps qu'on n'a pas un accord de
coopération
est-ce que vous assumez ce soir d'abord
j'ai voulu rappeler un débat qui est un
peu j'allais dire un submersible qui
revient en régulièrement à toutes les
élections présidentielles c'est un débat
un peu interdit c'est le débat la
recherche de solutions efficaces pour
que des personnes qui ont été condamnées
qui n'ont pas la réalité française
qu'ils n'auront jamais vu leur
comportement pays que
soient renvoyés dans leur pays une fois
qu'ils ont purgé leur peine
qu'est-ce qu'ils font s'ils ne rentrent
pas dans leur pays ils sont là et nargue
l'autorité de l'état et les cent mille
personnes n'ont pas sans lui il ya cent
mille personnes qui ont une obligation
de quitter le territoire français mais
il y a un certain nombre d'individus
certes identifié par la police de l'air
et des frontières des frontières ce qui
font l'objet de demandes de reconduite à
la frontière et ce sont les pays
d'origine qui refusent cette coopération
ils disent terroristes surtout pas on
n'en veut pas vous le gardez donc on va
garder comme ça un certain nombre de non
nationaux qui nous posait problème donc
j'ai voulu dire écoutez maintenant alors
taper au portefeuille mais de qui des
états d'abord sont les états qui sont en
cause car dans la recherche d'un rapport
de force diplomatique
il est nécessaire que les états bouger
accepte la coopération des états qu'on
finance sont d etat qu une diaspora en
effet qui participent à j'allais dire
leur niveau de vie ce sont des états
avec qui nous avons des relations
historiques très importante on est là
pour préciser votre pensée jauger vient
vous dites 11 milliards de transferts
vous savez ce que c'est ces transferts
ce sont les personnes qui sont sur notre
sol d'origine marocaine algérienne
malienne etc et qui envoient de l'argent
au bled comme on dit parfois en tout cas
au pays pour aider leur famille c'est ça
c'est 11 milliards c'est d'individu à
individu de famille la famille vous avez
dit on t'a pour le portefeuille on
bloque voulaient bloquer vous bloquez
des individus ou les punissent et je ne
veux pas je vais vous dire j'ai ressenti
beaucoup d'émoi
beaucoup d'émotion d'ailleurs mes
propres amis dans ma famille certains
pratiquent ce soutien
cette entraide par delà les frontières
oui parce que ils l'ont pris pour eux
mais non si on la prend comme ça oui
bien sûr et donc je n'ai pas voulu viser
les jambes j'ai voulu viser les états
donc moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est les
états pour que ça bouge donc il faut
jouer vers la d vous n'avez pas dit ce
que vous avez dit ce soir soyons clair
vous dites je sais pas exactement
voulait dire sa baisse et un coup mais
je ne sais pas si je me suis mal exprimé
parce que c'était très clair ce que j'ai
dit j'ai voulu j'ai voulu viser les
états et il est vrai que moi je ne
souhaite pas toucher ces familles qui
travaillent dur qui envoient de l'argent
dans famille de l'autre côté de la
méditerranée ou ailleurs où beaucoup
plus loin et donc est donc pour moi mon
sujet mon sujet c'est comment on tape au
portefeuille on admire sur le fond juste
sur la forme mais vous aviez improvisé
cette phrase elle vous est venu comme ça
parce que quand même vous l'avez dit
voilà vous et vous êtes dit forget avait
très très fort pour pour marquer les
mains je les ai pas c'est à dire le
débat maintenant mais sur cette non mais
sur cette question car il faut
sensibiliser nos compatriotes sur le
fait qu' aujourd'hui c'est un problème
et qui n'est pas traité le président de
la république a proposé la restriction
des visas j'ai l'impression que ça ne
fonctionne pas et le ça ne fonctionne
pas d'ailleurs les propositions qui sont
sur la table y en a pas vous entendez
évidemment les cris d'un certain nombre
de dirigeants de la gauche qui disent
c'est pas possible
d'accord mais quelles sont les
propositions c'est une boulette cause à
effet écoutez je pense que je me suis
fait engueuler par trop par des gens que
j'aime
les gens que j'aime chez moi aussi j'ai
des origines dans l'immigration comme
beaucoup de français
et je j'ai compris que je m'étais mal
exprimé c'est au sens où je me suis pas
fait comprendre de la véritable cible la
cible ce sont les états et quand jean
luc mélenchon ni reconnaissait une
erreur
hilarant on peut reconnaître une erreur
je pense que je ne dirais pas une erreur
je dirais que
c'est une incompréhension et je vais
vous dire on a besoin d'ailleurs de
chercher des solutions
l'élection présidentielle c'est fait oui
mais pas durant laquelle pas lourd mais
des solutions sur la table il est
recherché et en débattre c'est pas fait
pour mettre la poussière sous le tapis
vous êtes à 2% c'est un sondage ifop le
figaro lci il ya de ça derrière il
fallait faire une proposition choc
qu'ils mettent les feux sur vous écoutez
je n'ai pas je n'ai pas de stratégie de
cette nature j'ai une sincérité et une
passion pour la france je suis engagé je
ne veux pas porter tort
à ceux qui bossent dur et qui parce que
c'est mon essai sens de mon engagement
est certaine façon vous excuser les
avertis je pense que si j'en ai heurté
certains j'aurai à les dire j'en ai
heurté certains peut-être blessé
inquiété mais ce n'est pas pour eux que
cette mesure était destinée et je veux
dire qu' il s'agit maintenant d'ouvrir
et il va falloir qu'on s'habitue à
nouvelle forme de conflit tu alité de
rapports de force dans les relations
internationales
l'époque
où tout se passait bien est un peu
révolu d'ailleurs le monde le monde est
devenu un monde de rapport de force
pourquoi parce que vous n'y a plus de
structuration
de la géopolitique vous présente steeve
journal bonjour au sénat je vous
présente l amont un gamin pour lcp il
faut préciser un peu ce qu'on voulait
faire alors sur les états déjà vous
reconnaissez une maladresse mais vous
maintenez la mesure évoquée hier je vais
je la hais les ailes et passer au débat
elle n'est pas compris et vous l'a
maintenu dans vous le requérez je n'ai
pas à le retirer ou ou pas puisque elle
est candidate à la présidentielle à
l'aller dans le débat et vous l'a
maintenu que je sais je ce que je sais
c'est que elle est inefficace qu'elle ne
passe pas harry est incomprise bon donc
vous la retirez deuxièmement je pense
que il faut bien voir ce que j'ai voulu
faire
parler et s'occuper des états ça veut
dire attention proposition
agence française de développement nous
avons des accords de coopération avec
nombreux états subsahariens du maghreb
où nous finançons une partie de l'état
de ces états mais aussi des projets
est-ce que nous pouvons accepter que
quand nous demandons finalement
le retour des ressortissants qui ont été
condamnés ici on nous répond non non
vous retirer votre proposition vous avez
lancé l'idée vous retirer la pompe
en alternative deuxièmement la question
des avoirs des dirigeants est un sujet
il ya un sérum de procédures qui sont
ouvertes sur les biens mal acquis mais
ça c'est du judiciaire la question c'est
les avoirs des dirigeants qui est un
sujet aussi sur lequel et on ce sont les
américains qui font ça ils font les
américains le font ils l'ont fait
d'ailleurs
en afghanistan ils l'ont fait
vous allez voir c'est à voir vous avez
regardé je vais vous dire que la
question qui est posée la question qui
est posée sur les avoirs des dirigeants
c'est un certain nombre de
de biens qui aujourd'hui pourrait
relever d'un certain nombre
d'interrogations
le roi du maroc a des propriétés en
france je n'en sais rien après ça vous
dit si jamais il a calé pas tendre
ressortissants parents bloqués je ne
dirais pas ça mais je dirais que il y à
un panel de menaces il ya un panel de
menaces qu'il faut assumer et qu'il faut
le mettre sur la table de toute façon il
n'y a pas de propositions sur le sujet
il y en a pas donc il faut en trouver
une
travailler et revenir vers nous pour
presser elsa allez je vous parle
d'économie vous dis qu emmanuel macron à
un bilan économique désastreux la france
est dans la panade vous le répéter
pourtant les indicateurs sont au vert un
chômage bas du jamais vu avant 2008 la
croissance repart la france va mieux et
est ce que vous le voyez pas ou est ce
que vous ne voulez pas le voir je ne
sais pas de quoi vous parlez mais ce que
je sais c'est que les français
s'appauvrissent
que la balance commerciale a atteint un
record négatif seulement démentiel
puisque nous importons tout moins 85
milliards on est focalisé sur la dette
mais le plus grave c'est quand même le
fait que ce que nous exportons par
rapport à ce que nous importons on est
en déficit majeur le chômage baisse les
pouvoirs d'achat chômage baissent pas
pour tout le monde parce que le chômage
longue durée il n'a pas bougé
le chômage qui est intéressant encore 5
million et demi de chômeurs est encore à
8 je rappelle que tous les pays
européens dans la reprise de la préco
vides sont quasiment autour de 5 en
dessous de 5 5 c'est presque le plein
emploi on est au plein en poste entre 4
et 5 donc en fait ça va ça va par
rapport à ce qu'on a connu ça va mieux
heureusement parce qu'il ya une reprise
économique dans tous les pays européens
et puis surtout le vrai sujet c'est que
quand vous regardez tous les autres
indicateurs qui sont pas seulement le
chômage l'appauvrissement des français
c'est la question des salaires et des
revenus quand vous ajoutez la question
des services publics police justice
santé éducation c'est quand même c'est
quand même des services publics très
abîmée en très mauvais état avec une
crise morale à l'intérieur vous déplacer
en france en ter comme vous le dites
vous croisez que des gens pessimistes
des gens qui ne voient pas un avenir
heureux j'ai été frappé de voir dans ses
discussions avec les français
longue parce que on a le temps dans le
train et on prend le temps des gens qui
disaient moi vous savez ça va mais
franchement j'ai un désespoir collectif
et j'ai entendu cette expression en
disant moi je suis désespéré de mon pays
qui se cassent gentiment la figure et
tout le monde nous nous repensa en rose
comme si tout allait bien donc en fait
ce que les gens perçoivent c'est que il
ne voit pas quel est le projet notre
pays alors juste mais c'est la raison
pour laquelle je défends un projet alors
au monde tada de remonter c'est à dire
remettre la france au travail mais il
mieux le travail crée plus de travail
c'est fondamental le il ya 3 300 mille
emplois non pourvus ce thème en france
selon la banque de france il ya des
chômeurs il ya des emplois comment vous
expliquez ça est précisément quelles
sont vos propositions en la matière vous
avez beaucoup d'emplois non pourvus
parce que les salaires sont insuffisants
là où ils travaillent et traite et est
importante vous voulez monter les
salaires ont augmenté les salaires
proposés bien sûr une augmentation du
smic qui est importante 10 ans minimum
vous arrivez ce sera la première mesure
oui
125 euros de plus par mois tout de suite
mais surtout comment refaire comment s'y
prendre pour augmenter le smic etc ça
s'appelle un décret et les patrons sont
d'accord pour augmenter le smic de 10%
roquettes pas mais je vais je suis
moi-même
dirigeants d'entreprise j'ai entendu le
patron de la fédération du medef et de
la fédération hôtellerie restauration
qui a déclaré je vais augmenter et faire
une proposition à ma branche une
augmentation des salaires de 9% donc on
n'est pas très loin en fait puis je vais
vous dire il ya le sujet aussi
l'objection arrive tout de suite
et les autres salaires ou en dessous de
2000 euros brut il ne peut pas augmenter
le smic parce qu'on va pas mettre tout
le monde au smic n'est ce pas seulement
donc on va augmenter le smic mais aussi
les autres salaires et conditions les
plus bas salaires alors que donc là je
préconise propose même pas une
préconisation c'est même une obligation
je propose une qu'on n'a pas fait depuis
mai 68 en fait les grenelles y en a eu
mais le grenelle des salaires le dernier
c'était en 1968 à la mode à la
conférence salariale non mais une
conférence salariale
là la loi va devoir pouvoir sanctionner
cette négociation interprofessionnelle
branche par branche on va prendre les 57
métiers en tension là où il y à des
emplois non pourvus quand vous allez
dans n'importe quelle région de france
vous voyez les petites annonces qui sont
quand même légion avec et je rencontre
tous les jours des entrepreneurs qui me
dit j'arrive pas embaucher g3 poche et
10 postes cdd cdi alors vous les
présidents des groupements d'employeurs
agricoles
m'a dit j'ai 27 cdi 27 mille pardons cdi
pour aller dans les exploitations et
voulait un grenelle très concrètement
j'ai une mesure très concrète à vous
soumettre il ya le contrat d'engagement
qui a été annoncé par emmanuel macron la
semaine dernière 500 euros par mois pour
moins de 400 mille jeunes qui sont loin
de l'emploi en échange d'un
accompagnement précisément vers l'emploi
ou vers la formation c'est une bonne
nouvelle mesure c'est un accompagnement
vers la formation pour des décrocheurs
ce n'est pas une mauvaise mesure elle
est un c'est une réponse qu'elle mérite
d'exister mais est-ce que cela va mener
vers l'emploi il faudra le voir donc
laissons cette mesure s'exercer ce que
je sais c'est que la question
aujourd'hui de la formation n'est pas
traitée et pour moi il faut créer des
écoles dans les entreprises pourquoi
parce que c'est là que la formation et
la plus efficace en vous créer des
écoles dans les airs c'est ce que
j'appelle c'est l'internât de médecine
savez pourquoi pourquoi notre médecine
est si
brillante et rayonnante à l'extérieur et
enviée c'est parce que on a formé les
gens
sur le terrain pendant des années et en
afrique et ils ont appris c'est une
forme d'apprentissage mais de long cours
c'est pas 400 heures puis 400 heures
existe déjà beaucoup dans les métiers ça
égalise à man ça existe mais il n'y a
pas de candidat parce que ce n'est pas
attractif qu'il n'y a pas de garantie
d'emploi à la sortie puis surtout
beaucoup se posent la question de savoir
quel est le devenir de ces métiers dont
il n'y a pas suffisamment de finalement
de mobilisation nationale autour de ces
métiers qui sont des métiers très très
très beau métier des métiers où il y à
des carrières à faire des bons salaires
a gagné et de la promotion sociale je
rappelle que la fraude la première le
club la cohorte des ingénieurs c'est
d'abord les cours du soir dans notre
pays c'est pas les grandes écoles
pourquoi parce qu'il ya une 140 ça
existe déjà dans certaines régions d
apprentissage avec des cd avec les
comment vous accompagner les entreprises
à payer mieux leurs salariés ça ça
m'intéresse à leur maillot valérie
pécresse elle dit du pourfendeur
augmentation des salaires je passe les
cotisations sociales voilà j'accompagne
j'ai des entreprises que vous faites
j'ai 2 2 une remarque une proposition la
première remarque c'est que les
salaires en dessous de 1,6 fois le smic
sont déjà essentiellement des charges et
c'est à dire qu'il n'ya pas de la 500
euros environ de cotisations sociales et
les employeurs disent oui c'est vrai on
sait acceptable augmentation de salaire
parce que l'essentiel c'est du net la
deuxième qui sait attendre et position
c'est de basculer une grande partie de
la du financement de la protection
sociale qui aujourd'hui ces taxes
l'emploi le travail les salaires
l'embauchent et le passé sur ce qu'on
appelle finalement le capital travail
c'est à dire un des soldes de
l'entreprise qui permet qui permettrait
de soulager les industries de main
d'oeuvre et les entreprises qui
embauchent peu ou qui ont peu d'oeuvre
mais qui ont des très bons résultats de
cotiser davantage à la protection
sociale un exemple pour être clair une
entreprise de 250 millions qui à 2000
salariés qui aujourd'hui se paye
énormément de protection sociale parce
qu'elle à 2000 salariés et donc à la
démarche difficile paierez moins mais
une entreprise qui fait 40 millions de
chiffre d'affaires mais avec 20 salariés
en paieraient beaucoup plus et ce serait
finalement une sorte de neutralisation
du système
arnaud montebourg demain emmanuel macron
va s'exprimer devant les français
qu'attendez-vous de cette adresse aux
français la dernière fois c'était le 12
juillet dernier écoutez je n'attends pas
grand-chose du président de la
république parce que on a déjà fière
pardon en général d'ailleurs non oui en
général pourquoi parce que les discours
n'engagent que ceux qui les écoutent
d'abord et puis qui les croient ensuite
monsieur macron a fait beaucoup de
discours dans tous les sens et
d'ailleurs je ne pense pas que si on
mettait au regard de ses discours ce que
il a fait moi je me suis un un discours
il avait dit on va faire un plan
marshall la réindustrialisation alors la
tête du plan marshall de monsieur macron
c'est quoi ben c'est alstom démonter
vendu aux américains technique vendu aux
américains et des ja l'algérie 1030
quand même qu'ils annoncent en attendait
le plan marshall c'est au début de son
mandat
lafarge vendus aux suisses alcatel vendu
au finlandais et si l'or aux italiens du
sanitaire demain ce sera surtout du
sanitaire mais je ne sais pas de quoi
vous parlez vous vous le savez mais moi
pas ce que je sais c'est que quand
monsieur macron fait des annonces on est
à peu près sûr que ça n'a aucun rapport
avec le résultat donc comment se fait-il
qu'on en est au troisième plan
d'investissement a fait des cinq ans
bientôt pouvoir plus deux ans ça fait
sept ans déjà 3e plan investissement il
100 milliards 50 milliards 30 milliards
pour 2030 alors que il et il m'a
remplacé à bercy il ya sept ans et ils
pouvaient tout de suite le fait rien on
en reviendra tout à l'heure d'ailleurs
avec un parlementaire un mot quand même
sur le sanitaire et financement de laval
a pas de la sécu mais l'organisation
parce que en ce moment le parlement
discute du budget de la sécu le sénat
propose de taxer davantage les mutuelles
est ce que vous y être favorables
écoutez si on taxe les mutuelles qui
d'ailleurs est déjà le cas puisqu'elle
parvient quant à finhan ce moment de la
sécurité sociale les mutuelles vont
reporter les montants dans les prix des
vous êtes contre
mesures est ce que c'est une mesure pour
gagner pour prendre de l'argent sur une
mesure incitative je comprends ça c'est
bien julien déficit y ait un autre grand
chantier en cours qui a été lancé par le
gouvernement l'hypothèse de créer une
grande sécu qui absorberait précisément
ces mutuelles vous êtes pour vous êtes
contre écoutez je ne sais pas parce que
je connais pas le projet ce que je sais
c'est absorbé je sais pas combien de
centaines de milliers de salariés dans
les mutuelles mais si c'est un projet
décidé destiné à faire des économies ça
veut dire hier un plan social massif
dans les mutuelles de justice sociale
aussi bas je ne sais pas ce que je sais
c'est que ce projet mérite d'être
examinée ce n'est pas une mauvaise idée
que d'amener tous les français avoir une
meilleure couverture sociale avec un
financement universel mais comment
va-t-on s'y prendre avec les mutuelles
mais je n'ai pas de réponse à cette
question est là une question arnaud
montebourg sur la chasse vous chassez
peut-être non je ne chasse pas non alors
pour ou contre sur le sénat ya une
pétition soixante quinze mille français
sont favorables à ce qu'on interdise la
chasse le mercredi et le samedi
est ce que vous signez cette proposition
non je ne signe pas cette proposition
d'abord parce que je crois que pour moi
la chasse est un loisir populaire qui
était acquis à la révolution française
sur la noblesse le droit de chasse
étaient réservés à la noblesse a été
acquise par le peuple est aujourd'hui
ceux qui ont les moyens de chasser à le
font quand ils ne travaillent pas c'est
à dire le week-end donc il faut trouver
les modalités de vie en commun dans les
forêts je pense qu'on est capable de le
faire l'achat serait et les
interdictions elles sont déjà nombreuses
elles ont d'ailleurs évolué avec le
temps elles sont pour moi nécessaire
quand elles sont liées à la biodiversité
pourquoi parce que nous sommes très
attachés je suis très attaché à protéger
évidemment les disparitions d'espèces et
2 ce point de vue il y a un certain
nombre d'éléments de protection qui sont
rappelées par l'édition de justice
dernière ma chasse traditionnelle
vouziers de proposer on a des décisions
de justice auquel il faut se conformer
qui ont été prises donc vous êtes
content la chasse traditionnelle mais je
n'ai pas de position pour ou contre il
ya des décisions de justice qui ont été
prises parce qu'il y avait un problème
biodiversité c'est peut-être d'ailleurs
un problème qui évoluera dans le temps
il ya du surnuméraires par exemple sur
certaines certains animaux et sanglier
on en est infesté les chevreuils en a
beaucoup trop
donc on a besoin qu'il y ait une
régulation par la chasse et faut donc
l'interdiction en soit me paraît est une
mesure excessive ça doit être
pragmatique département par département
en fonction des problèmes de
biodiversité
si je veux être raisonnable je pense
qu'on peut le faire comme ça et pour
conclure tant barbara pompili dans la
foulée de sa demande d'interdiction de
chasse des on va ouvrir le débat à la
raison on vous dira débat il faut en
discuter d'accord on n'est jamais contre
les débats simplement je trouve que la
manière dont on débat dans ce pays me me
paraît à coups de pétitions état il ya
des positions qui doivent s'exprimer
évidemment mais il faut qu'on arrive à
trouver des points de compromis et d
équilibre merci beaucoup elsa est est
une toute petite curiosité mais ce que
je vous ai pas entendu là-dessus on va
pas ouvrir un grand chapitre mais justes
vont parler d'économie l'impôt sur le
revenu son barème aujourd'hui est ce que
vous y toucher est ce que vous le
laisser intact vous estimez que en
termes de redistribution
écoutez je crois que le vrai sujet pour
moi c'est les exilés fiscaux et pour
noah pour moi c'est là c'est là qu'il
faut mettre le paquet pour la réforme
fiscale pour moi ma proposition kanza et
le passeport français vont payer aux
impôts en france c'est une révolution
fiscale ont répondu à ma question vous
touchez pas aux besoins ajouté pas si on
va aller chercher l'impôt sur le revenu
à ceux qui sont partis donc c'est une
application beaucoup plus ferme de la
loi existante
je vous présente d'abord extraire du
figaro qui dans quelques instants
vous posez des questions évidemment
politique mais d'abord un détour par le
figaro life vincent au bon soir vincent
bonsoir elizabeth martichoux
montebourg vous avez beaucoup de
questions des lecteurs du figaro quelle
est la première ce soir alors il ya une
question qui est posée également aux
lecteurs du figaro c'est au tour de la
troisième dose beaucoup de lecteurs du
figaro revienne sur sa est-ce qu'il faut
ouvrir la troisième dose de vaccin au
moins de 65 ans
les internautes du figaro sont
favorablement pour alors vous arnaud
montebourg qui avait vu comme une
humiliation
l'absence de vaccin français contrôle
commande c'est ce que vous écrivez dans
votre livre quel est votre avis sur la
question
d'abord je veux préciser que j'ai eu
comme idée que je suis vacciné et que je
conseille à tout le monde de se faire
vacciner car c'est une maladie
extrêmement destructrice et qu' il est
difficile de remonter la pente quand on
l'a contractée et ça a été mon cas
mais tout va bien après mais néanmois
c'est un moment difficile je trouve que
la question des vaccins aujourd'hui
telle qu'elle est imaginez risque de
nous entraîner
trop loin nous avons déjà deux doses
pour tous ceux qui sont là qui est ce
que cette protection est suffisante je
n'arrive pas à voir la démonstration
qu'elle serait insuffisante est ce que
cette protection ne pourrait pas suffire
pour passer les éventuels rémission de
laval pardon réapparition de la maladie
je le pense je pense que nous pouvons
faire face à cela j'ai aussi une demande
vis à vis du gouvernement puisque nous
avons raté le vaccin quelles sont les
propositions et où en est le
gouvernement pour sortir les traitements
de haut niveau sur lesquelles on
pourrait protéger une partie de la
population il ya aujourd'hui dans le
monde beaucoup de médecins qui sont les
médecins de terrain des professeurs
d'université qui se pose la question du
traitement et je trouve que le débat
national qui est obsédé par le vaccin ne
à juste titre d'ailleurs ne traite pas
suffisamment des solutions alternatives
alors j'ai vu apparaître ici ou là un
salon d'éléments donc moi je voudrais
qu'on ouvre le débat sanitaires ça ira
très pense vincent
peut-être une petite question est ce que
vous auriez est ce que vous êtes
favorable au projet de loi de vigilance
sanitaire tel qu'il a été voté par
l'assemblée nationale non j'y suis
défavorable je trouve que la
disproportion des mesures posent un
problème de liberté publique c'est le
moment de d'adapter beaucoup plus
précisément les atteintes aux libertés
aux menaces existantes et je trouve
qu'il ya une disproportion une
disproportion entre l'une et l'autre
dernière question pour conclure vincent
juste est ce que vous pouvez dire vous
dites je suis pas pour la 3è dos et dire
que ce soit vous ne dites pas aux
personnes et les gma troisième blues
allaient faire là dedans je veux dire je
dis est ce que céline a dit non je n'ai
pas dit ça j'ai dit c'est non mais je
vous demande si vous diriez aller faire
la troisième pause non je dirais je
dirais à ceux qui je dirais et c'est ce
que je dis le gouvernement qui s'engage
sur la voie de la troisième dose je n'ai
pas aujourd'hui les éléments je peux
changer d'opinion mais je n'ai pas
aujourd'hui les éléments qui me permette
de penser que c'est une bonne politique
merci beaucoup vincent a tout à l'heure
un vous revenez pour
arnaud montebourg je vous faire un
compliment vous êtes un fin politique
parce que vous êtes rentré dans ce
studio avec un préjugé de probablement
de l'opinion et beaucoup de la classe
politique de droite avec votre
proposition formulée hier sur comme quoi
vous alliez interrompre les transferts
de fonds vis-à-vis de 2,2 des pays qui
ne respectent pas les règles du jeu en
récupérant leur leurs ressortissants
indésirables et vous vous êtes en train
de faire un virage à gauche sur un sujet
vous connaissez très bien celui de la
corruption des biens mal acquis vous
avez beaucoup travaillé sur ce sujet
comme avocat faut qu avec l'association
survie souvenez vous c'était il ya
quelques années est donc là maintenant
vous êtes vous êtes refait une virginité
de gauche écoutez je n'ai pas que c'est
de la corruption qu'il est question
maintenant c'est plus du tout la même
proposition qui hier c'est une
proposition complémentaire je vais vous
dire pourquoi pas et d'ailleurs elle
doit être sur la table
les investissements que la direction du
trésor que l' agence française de
développement que l'union européenne que
le fmi font ensemble dans ces
territoires alors que nous ce sont des
territoires des pays amis et qui ne
coopèrent pas sur les questions de
sécurité pour nous qui sont centrales et
qui sont pour nous une atteinte à
l'autorité de l'état il admissible
et humiliante oui humiliante et bien il
est évident qu'il va falloir sévir donc
évidemment on va dire à ben alors vous
allez
retirer des projets de développement
dans ces pays va bien on en discutait
déjà donc moi pour moi c'est un panel de
menaces rae qui doit s'exercer parce que
aujourd'hui la diplomatie ne fonctionne
pas nous n'avons pas réussi à exécuter
les les décisions de reconduite à la
frontière et les pays qui d'onde on sait
leurs ressortissants ont commis un
certain nombre d'actes criminels ou
délictueux sur notre territoire ne sont
pas acceptés par les pays si vous êtes
si vous arrivez à l'elysée vous allez
vous mettre à dos une bonne partie de
l'afrique noire et de l'afrique du nord
d'ailleurs aussi et qui sont classés
quand même l'afrique francophone pour
beaucoup de pays ça va être ça va pas
être simple écoutez
j'ai envie de vous dire il faut trancher
les problèmes on ne peut pas vivre dans
l'hypocrisie je les dis sur le sur le
débat en maudit a pas de problème c'est
pas grave pas en parler ainsi on en
parle les débats interdits c'est ce qui
fait que on a des mourres dans tous les
postes de télévision c'est parce que
comme personne n'at il y en a qui s'en
emparent à féliciter lui zemmour pour
cette proposition même le voir à l'écran
tient la phrase d'eric vous voilà
justement une question parce que zemmour
vous à féliciter mais je cherche la
tactique guerrière ça est ce que
finalement les avec les dit tout à
l'heure vous êtes à 2% 2 3% dans le
sondage vous avez beaucoup de sénateurs
socialistes qui vous suivent est ce que
finalement ils n'ont pas dû être très
contents ces sénateurs socialistes de
cette proposition quand je pense à mon
amoureux signol quand je pense à
d'autres à monsieur morin qui est à
l'europe je pense à mme lienemann ils
ont dû
se détourner un petit peu de boue en
disant mais c'est pas du tout ceux de la
maison compris que c'était une volonté
de taper du poing sur la table d'ouvrir
le débat et de commencer à créer les
conditions d'un rapport de force avec
nous
et pour gagner aussi quelques
pourcentages non non je ne dirais pas ça
parce que ce n'est pas notre j'ai envie
de vous dire
dans la sincérité des convictions les
choses s'exprime et y compris les les
erreurs qu'on peut commettre jeu des
mois je me suis je me suis fait
engueuler ouais par des amis et ma
propre famille oui on dit quand même là
jusque parce que parce que nous on le
fait et on en a besoin il aurait dit la
grand mère au caveau origine
la gauche vous ne vous en revendiquer
plus
qui êtes vous de quoi arnaud montebourg
est le nom alors d'abord il est inexact
de dire je n'en revendique pas d'abord
sait jamais dans votre bouche j'ai
toujours dit je le dis réglages il un
homme de gauche mais je me tourne vers
les problèmes des français la gauche a
souffert de s'enfermer dans ses pas
seulement ces querelles mais ses propres
sujets qu'est ce qu'être mais
abbas est assez simple je vais vous dire
ce que c'est ce gros chat fruits c'est
s'occuper des classes populaires qui ne
gagnent pas leur vie en travaillant
c'est s'occuper des gens qui n'ont que
leur travail pour vivre c'est s'occuper
de ceux qui ne peuvent pas travailler
parce qu'il ya pas assez de travail dans
ce pays manque un million d'emplois
au bas mot pour que nous ayons un gâteau
qui financent suffisamment gros qui
financent la protection sociale et en ma
stratégie qu'elle qu'elle était c'est
pas faire des réformes en tapant sur la
tête des français c'est en élargissant
les conditions de la production dans ce
pays c'est pour ça que je dis remettre
la france au travail pour pouvoir
justement financer et la transition
écologique et notre modèle social qui
est enviée dans le monde votre livre
remonte à lavau dit je voudrais tu le
aimé jacquet de la politique aimé
jacquet a eu des succès puisqu'elle a
gagné la coupe du monde en 1998 aimé
jacquet c'était quelqu'un qui était
plutôt rude avec ses troupes mais plutôt
sur un ton assez doux nom assez bon père
de c'est un personnage que j'ai adoré il
vous fascine adoré nom et mais c'est mal
aimé aimé jacquet pourquoi parce que il
avait de la fermeté et en même temps de
l'écouter il était capable de dire bon
bah oui on s'est trompé on va faire
comme ça et surtout il travaillait en
équipe moi je pense moi je ne suis je
suis anti jupiter c'est à dire le mythe
du dieu du ciel et de la terre 1 et qui
décide de tout et projette la foudre
pour réaliser
de faux espoirs parce qu'en fait c'est
tout à fait ça je préfère et c'est ça
l'esprit de la remonte à la sela
métaphore l'image sportive consiste à
dire on s'unit entre nous on n'a pas
beaucoup de ressources parce que on est
quand même opération commando très très
très bas est en difficulté on est dans
la panade et donc il va falloir que en
peu de temps on rattrape notre tard
d'accord et on va se refaire et on peut
le faire avec des gens et c'est ma
vision des choses quand je parle du
conseil national de la résistance le
trait assez intéressant parce que c'est
une vision stratégique que j'ai deux
sets de ma candidature je considère
qu'il nous faut
comme dans les temps anciens dès 1945
quand il a fallu reconstruire le pays
bas eu des alliances avec les
socialistes et communistes et golinger
la main xavier bertrand mais je
n'entends pas la main je défends une
stratégie qui consiste à dire alors il
va falloir que tous ces gens qui pensent
qu'ils vont gouverner avec 20% et ça
vaut pour monsieur macron ou 25% et
gaullistes aux communistes jeudi des
colis sony c'est à dire qu'il faut
sortir de son clan de son de sa
certitude est que c'est il faut être
capable pardon je termine en france m
eur il faut être capable de construire
des compromis pour avancer c'est ce que
font tous les pays européens alors de
tous les pays européens à prendre de
questions justement d'alliance
cette grande alliance je dirais pour
reconstruire notre pays elle exclut
zemmour et le pen elle exclut tous ceux
qui piétinent
c'est leur cap qui piétine notre
héritage
notre république
la sphère la manière dont
zemmour crasse sur la résistance
réhabilite la milice
insultes général de gaulle réhabilite le
maréchal pétain
simple on a passé on a passé des heures
devant la croix de lorraine les 18 juin
quand j'étais parlementaire on a mené
les enfants des écoles pour dire
n'oubliez pas et des gens qui ont risqué
leur vie pour défendre notre liberté
notre droit d'être
indépendant et sa il ya un gars qui
écrit dans un qui écrit des livres
depuis des années et qui crache
maintenant c'est inadmissible donc il
est il s'est mis en dehors de la
commission
un candidat à l'élection présidentielle
qui était votre place il ya pas très
longtemps ici même qui vous tendait la
main qui disait avec arnaud montebourg
je pourrais travailler on a des sujets
communs notamment la défense du
nucléaire ou développement du nucléaire
oui à qui je fais référence et fabien
gabel qu'est le secrétaire national du
parti communiste
est ce que cette main où la saisie c est
ce que vous lui répondez quelque chose
de positif a je crois qu'il a d'abord
c'est une personne que j'estime beaucoup
dans la fermeté de ses convictions
je trouve que les positions qu'il défend
sont des positions constructives sa
vision de l'écologie nous sommes assez
proches sa vision du social et de
l'économie finalement nous sommes à ses
voisins
donc nous avons des points de
compréhension mutuelle et ça c'est
précieux dans la période actuelle et
pourvoient la bague cultivons les gars
vont laver le alors non s'est vue
d'accords fait du bien si on se parle et
moi j'ai beaucoup j'ai vraiment beaucoup
d'estimé pour lui encore un petit mot
sympa et et vous avez dit tout à l'heure
à bien finir à reconnaître ses nerfs en
politique c'est ce soit souligné bon
mais certains disent cette erreur allez
y et la sécurisation des esprits vous en
êtes aussi victime ça a été un bien
coûter la proposition
qui a été formulée hier à montgallet wii
qui a été formulée hier est une
proposition qui est issue directement
des politiques des américains les
américains ils font ça ils gèlent les
avoirs
c'est joe biden qui a mis en oeuvre sa
en afghanistan c'est barack obama à
camille ça en oeuvre en iran c'est lé
transfert et les avoir sauf qu'on a du
mal à passer des transferts des
particuliers mais c'est une fortune mais
des dirigeants messianique c'est le cas
c'était le cas de ce qu'ont fait les
présidents américains c'est une
constante de l'extraterritorialité
américaine et nous devons nous m
commencez pas commencer à imaginer ça
pourquoi parce qu'on ne peut pas se
laisser dans vos réponses des nominés je
ne suis pas j'ai pas été et morizet
quelques minutes sur la juger et émail
denise est alors un à ce cas là comme
d'ailleurs sur le plan d'investissement
oui je cours après joe biden comme par
ailleurs sur les hausses de salaires le
président byden propose une hausse des
salaires minima me fédéral américain je
sais pas si le congrès laissera faire de
15 $ 15 $ 15 euros peu près 14 euros oui
la voilà merci très rare merci roue et
vous connaissez la règle de cette
émission va accueillir deux
parlementaires pendant qu'ils entrent un
mot du débat et l'air ce soir c'est le
premier débat de cette primaire fermée
tout à l'heure sur lci sont tous les
mêmes c'est c'est bonnet blanc et blanc
bonnet les ailes et les cinq candidats
qui je ne sais pas je ne sais pas je je
je
je suis assez attentifs à leur
proposition je serai très heureux de
l'est de les entendre voir où ils en
sont ce qu'ils ont à déclarer sur
l'ensemble des sujets bonjour messieurs
vous salue
écoutez nous sommes c'est un peu tôt
pour déjà faire l'élection donc jeu en
ce qui me concerne j'ai un enfant vous
j'ai ouï j'ai quelques idées sur ce que
je pourrais faire mais pour l'instant je
ne sais pas ce qu'il pourrait faire
laurent saint martin bonsoir député la
république en marge du val de marne
merci d'être avec nous jean raymond et
bonnet merci beaucoup vous êtes sénateur
l'est républicain de l'essonne vous avez
tous les deux choisi vous avez votre
carte blanche tout à l'heure chacun
d'eux vous posera une question arnaud
montebourg particulière mais votre thème
commun c'est la france et l'europe
laurent saint martin vous commencer
petit préliminaire très brefs et surtout
c'est le débat qui nous intéresse vous
le savez bien merci d'abord de votre
invitation monsieur montebourg bonsoir
bonsoir monsieur effectivement l'europe
pendant la crise au lendemain de la
crise a été au coeur des débats et a
démontré je crois ce qu'elles avaient de
meilleur au lendemain d'une grande
période où l'europe était très souvent
décrié je crois par notamment vous et
beaucoup d'autres responsables
politiques
puisque c'est le débat qui nous
intéresse ma question 1 sera très simple
et très direct est ce que vous
considérez qu'à travers à la fois toutes
les mesures d'urgence mesure shourd
mesure de l'abbaye que l'europe et la
construction européenne a pu mettre en
place notamment en apprenant de la crise
précédente celle de 2008 et ses
conséquences que vous avez bien connu au
gouvernement mais aussi et surtout par
le plan de relance exceptionnel de 750
milliards d'euros avec cette nouvelle
dette mutualisée
est ce que vous considérez aujourd'hui
que c'est une avancée une avancée
évidemment en termes de soutien aux
peuples européens mais aussi surtout une
avancée politique
merci monsieur le député de cette
présentation complète
pour moi l'union européenne dans la
période de l'après crise financière a
été la pourvoyeuse de plans d'austérité
qui se sont retournés contre les classes
moyennes et les classes populaires et
les gouvernements nationaux ont été les
exécutants de cette politique pendant la
crise du coc vide on a suspendu les
traiter parce qu'il n'y avait pas
d'autre solution et parce que c'était
raisonnable et parce qu'on ne pouvait
pas les appliquer tout simplement alors
qu'est-ce qui est selon vous une avancée
je voudrais revenir et le discuter vous
ai dit voilà il ya une dette commune oui
ou non le plan de relance oui mais il ya
vous adulez dans son plan de relance je
le juge totalement défavorable à nos
intérêts même si c'est une bonne idée au
plan européen oui soyons nuancé
raisonnable
le la faire
de la dette commune c'est qu'en fait il
n'y a pas de recette commune donc
finalement il ya une dette commune on
lève ensemble de l'argent pour financer
le plan de relance mais seulement des
étapes qui vont vous et d'ailleurs ça
doit venir et d'ailleurs c'est
exactement la conditionnalité qui a fixé
la commission européenne sur les états
membres que dans la trajectoire
budgétaire qui étaient
fixés par le gouvernement et envoyé à
bruxelles comme la copie du bon élève il
voit la trajectoire budgétaire de
rétablissement des comptes publics donc
on peut déjà annoncer puisque bruno le
maire le miz d'économie l'a lui-même
commenté je crois publiquement disant eh
bien c'est 72 milliard de dépenses en
diminution donc on est reparti dans les
plans d'austérité donc là pour moi si
vous voulez le plan de relance c'est
d'abord ce n'est pas tout à fait un plan
lancé un plan de relance ou contrainte
d'austérité futur ensuite deuxième
critique et je termine c'est que on
reçoit 40 milliards mais on va
rembourser 67 alors là effectivement
vous ne prenez pas en compte les
ressources propres qui seront évidemment
nécessaire à l'échelle européenne pour
rembourser la dette l'idée évidemment
pas que les pays et les états membres
rembourser des dettes sinon on ne change
rien au système là dessus vous avez
raison et l'enjeu notamment de la taxe
carbone aux frontières de la taxe sur la
finance et monsieur le député maire n'a
pas encore vous savez mieux que
quiconque on ne crée pas des ressources
bruxelles en quelques mois et la
présidence française de l'union
européenne va porter sa notamment sur le
tapis mais il faut pas le porter la
question monsieur montebourg n'a pas
répondu à ma question est ce que oui ou
non l'europe à mieux protéger à mieux
protéger les européens dont les français
pendant la crise qu'elle ne l'avait fait
pendant la crise précédente où avez vous
vu l'once le début d'une austérité
pendant cette crise de la part de
l'union européenne mais également de la
part de ses états membres la vérité
c'est que à la fois par la politique
monétaire européenne et par les projets
d'investissement communs que sont le
plan de relance que nous avons tous mis
ensemble nous avons fait la réponse
inverse à la crise précédente c'est à
dire que nous avons accepté de nous
endetter de façon commune pour mieux
protéger mieux relancer notre économie
et ça marche j'y reviendrai tout à
l'heure ça marche parce qu'on crée de
l'emploi on crée de l'emploi ont baissé
les impôts c'est à dire
je vais vous dire ce sont pour moi les
états membres qui ont fait ça d'ailleurs
ce sont c'est vraiment l'union
européenne dans cette affaire pour moi
elle a bougé de quelques millimètres ce
que je vous le disais à l'instant des
plans de relance ou finalement reçoit 40
ont remboursé 67 quel est l'intérêt des
plans de relance ou finalement on lève
de l'argent ensemble mais finalement on
n'a pas les recettes en phase ou me dit
qu'elles vont arriver je l'espère il
faut les gens il faut les clubs et je ne
peut que le souhaiter donc vous êtes
d'accord non je n'aurai que le mécanisme
dans des temps comme ainsi on trouve des
ressembler on l'a demandé pendant tant
d'années ma vérité c'est que c'est pas
l'endettement commun qui compte c'est
les recettes commune très bien et les
recettes commune 0 pour l'instant une
taxe sur les plastiques rossa peux pas
te laisser bien naturel de monter le
système de ressources propres après
l'endettement commun quand vous êtes
face à une crise comme celle ci met donc
je suis heureux vraiment de vous
entendre dire que je vous dis un plan de
relance était une bonne solution mais je
vends que laurier fait mais je pense que
c'est une bonne solution mais pour
l'instant rien n'est résolu
jean-raymond
ça c'est pas mal aussi
à l'ordinateur vous êtes de gauche vous
êtes candidat à la présidentielle en
2022 je suis de droite et modestement je
soutiens un candidat qui n'est autre que
michel barnier
bien sûr et ce qui est intéressant vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure c'est ce qui
rapproche
il ya quelque chose d'intéressant en
2011 2012 vous avez travaillé
quelqu'un est venu travailler avec vous
quelqu'un que je juge comme étant dans
la nouvelle génération quelqu'un d'assez
exceptionnel qui s'appelle david djaïz
et david djaïz dit des choses sur le
nacional versus l'europe et comment les
deux sont miscibles et je voulais savoir
à l'instar de ce que dit d'ailleurs
michel barnier sur l'article 88 de la
constitution
comment est et comment vous vous
inscrivez dans l'article 88
cette arme innoncent soyez un peu pédago
pour sa conduite de notre si belle
institution c'est l'article qui traitent
justement deux on va dire de la
modification de la constitution
donc pour modifier la question la
question elle est simple comment quand
l'actualité l'exigent l'urgence
l'exigent comment le droit national
redevient supérieur au droit européen et
mattek la primera je suis pour une
réforme l'article 88 de la constitution
dans lequel à chaque fois que les
intérêts vitaux de notre pays sont
menacés le parlement en dernier ressort
exprimera la souveraineté nationale de
dire non on est désolé mais nous
écartons la règle européenne au profit
de la règle nationale ce sera
raisonnable homéopathiques mais
indispensable je prends un exemple
la commission européenne en vertu de ses
pouvoirs propres qui pour moi sont des
coups de force juridique permanent la
commission européenne ce et le coup
d'état permanent contre les états
nations
elle veut démanteler nos barrages
cellino de bages je partage avec vous
deuxièmement elle veut démanteler edf
edf en a besoin pour je partage et or
elle veut mettre aux 35 heures nous
allons la cour de justice de l'union
européenne veut mettre aux 35 heures nos
armées de quoi se mêle t elle alors on
fait la guerre 35 heures on s'arrête
voilà quand on a sauvé air france sur le
sénateur n'a mis 7 milliards sur la
table le gouvernement soutenu par
monsieur le député en a mis 7 milliard
sur la table et la commission européenne
a dit ah oui vous pouvez se
sauver air france klm mais à condition
que vous donniez des créneaux
d'atterrissage et de décollage à orly
pour les compagnies low cost anglo saxon
concurrentes merci donc on a droit de
faire voler air france à nouveau lui
coupant les ailes donc ça c'est
inadmissible je vous dis
c'est à la carte je vous dirais et elle
vous dire une chose y'a pas que l'europe
aujourd'hui n'est pas à la carte bien
sûr que oui il ya des engagements
qu'elles étaient prêts quand les
parlements
je vais vous dire madame martichoux
d'abord les français ont voté non je le
rappelle donc déjà les engagements qui
ont été pris moi je les ai pas pris j'ai
pas voté
j'ai respecté le suffrage universel du
référendum de 2005
premièrement deuxièmement ce n'est pas
pour ça que je nie l'existence de ces
traités ces traités sont suspendus
aujourd'hui en plus donc la question
n'est pas celle là la question c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on fait comme europe
maintenant après les leçons du coc vide
et ça va nous intéresser donc dans le
débat est bien pour moi l'europe elle
doit s'occuper de l'extérieur des
menaces les empires nous protéger contre
les gars femmes le l'abus de pouvoir de
marché des chinois
s'intéresser régler problèmes
climatiques y compris sur les émissions
de centrales à charbon sur le sol
européen avant d'aller faire la leçon
aux chinois ou aux américains pologne
allemagne en tête ça c'est le boulot de
l'europe mais nous pendant ce temps là
on va s'occuper de notre vie domestique
alors ça c'est intéressant parce que
nous l'avons en partage monsieur
montebourg ce que vous exprimez je lai
en partage avec vous c'est très utile
oui c'est très utile et ce n'est pas
l'europe à la carte c'est éviter
justement que ce bien commun que nous
avons qui est l'europe absolument
indispensable il soit dilapidé et que le
bric site fasse des petits c'est surtout
ça l'urgence aujourd'hui absolue de
l'europe ce n'est pas de nier ce que
l'europe nous apporte quel français
pourrait nier la politique agricole
commune quel français pour les nier ça
donc c'est pas c'est pas c'est une autre
europe que celle qu'on nous a fabriqué
aujourd'hui et qui est un échec voilà
compromis redon méchant là il ya un
accord sur ce point sur la méthode et
sur ce qu'on voudrait faire de l'ordre
je vais vous dire là ce que je propose
le fait que la loi nationale soit
supérieure à la décision européenne
c'est exactement ce sur quoi nous avons
fonctionné jusqu'en 1989 c'est ce qu'on
appelle alex posterior terre la loi
postérieure du parlement national
prévalait sur la directive européenne et
je vais vous dire les allemands l'ont
appelé en matière monétaire le tribunal
constitutionnel de cazaux a dit moi ma
constitution elle me dit ça donc
n'accepte pas les décisions en c1 de
toute façon quand un petit choix
contestables mais je voudrais j'aime
bien oui mais c'est pourtant c'est
pourtant ce qui est en train de se
passer c'est que l'europe des nations
n'est pas morts on va faire les lois
elles sont intéressantes 1 l'europe des
nations n'est pas morte rien de mais
elle doit les peuples ont besoin de
pouvoir respirer oui bon n'allons pas
passer sous la toile et on va parler de
la sixième république c'est par leurs
prêts elle ment pas j'ai donné
la carte blanche alors la carte blanche
on parlait de constitution tout à
l'heure mais très rapidement 2001 vous
étiez
pour justement une révision
constitutionnelle et vous militiez pour
une réduction en tout cas une réduction
du du pouvoir du président de la
république en 2017 vous êtes favorable
au septennat en 2001 c'était le
quinquennat bien évidemment en 2017 vous
êtes favorable au septennat non
renouvelables et à une dénomination
réduite pour le président de la
république en 2022 pareil vous n'arrivez
pas changé non non c'est un projet que
j'ai j'ai écrit avec des juristes il ya
20 ans oui déjà 15 ans la constitution
de la nouvelle république était alors
certains 10 6e 5e bis en fait on s'en
fiche des numéros en fait c'est un
retour à quoi au rééquilibrage des
pouvoirs oui nous sommes là dans le
pouvoir d'un seul où sont les collèges
les décisions elles se prennent
collégialement dans les entreprises si
on donnait le pouvoir insolent de faire
tout et n'importe quoi
les entreprises ne marcherait pas on le
sait donc là le fonctionnement je n'ose
dire autocratique parce que ce serait
désagréable mais en fait solitaire
est extrêmement fâché et ça pose
beaucoup de problèmes et ça pose des
problèmes quand le président est bon ou
quand il est pas bon c'est pas une
question de personnes c'est un problème
de système veineux est donc le deuxième
élément c'est donc le contre-pouvoir
premiers éléments le deuxième élément
c'est l'intervention des citoyens
il ya eu dans le mouvement des gilet
jaune un acquis très intéressant très
important qu'on voyait apparaître dans
les seize mille cahiers de doléances que
j'ai fait l'effort d'aller lee dans
certains départements avec mon équipe
les gens il posait le problème de la fin
du mois et des problèmes de du droit de
vivre finalement de son travail mais
surtout il disait quand est ce qu'on va
avoir le droit est posée brême du
référendum d'initiative citoyenne quand
est ce qu'on va avoir le droit de
parfois pouvoir reprendre le contrôle je
suis pour organiser un référendum
de cette nature dans
d'abord parce qu'on a pas eu de
référendum puis 17 ans c'est surtout que
les gens ont perdu confiance en les
personnels politiques parce que la
réforme en tout cas à chaque fois qu'il
y à eut prononcé la vème république
dans les cinq premières années dans les
trente premières années pardon il ya eu
5 la révision dans les 30 dernières 19 c
de la frénésie et chacune a apporté
hormis celles qui nous sont imposées par
l'europe
les autres ont été des échecs le
quinquennat en tête et l'inversion du
calendrier
qui a donné tous les pouvoirs au
président de la république donc moi je
fais partie de ceux qui pensent que la
vème république et la bonne ya pas
besoin de bétheny de la sixième en tout
cas il ya besoin pour le personnel
politique d'être à la hauteur de ce
texte ce qui redonnera confiance au
public versé par le mans saint martin et
que l'on se retrouvera dans la 6ème
république vouliez pas supprimer le
travail de monsieur le sénateur
garments de la maison non non j'ai
toujours défendu mes l'entrée des
conseils
du doigt la non non non il ne l'est pas
donc pas dedans pas dans mon projet le
le conseil économique et social qui
représente finalement ce qu'on appelle
les corps intermédiaires
les les entrepreneurs la jeunesse et en
se disant désolé j'ai je veux qu'ils
deviennent sénateurs voilà donc ses
entrées au sénat pourquoi parce que il
faut qu'ils à boire à une chambre
législative au pas les lois de la même
façon qu elle le fait aujourd'hui
laurent saint martin alors ça va être un
exercice de style c'est un sujet et dont
l'enjeu majeur qui nous passionne tous
les deux et on a trois minutes oui
monsieur montebourg je voulais vous
parler d'emplois industriels et je vous
reconnais une vraie qualité vous êtes
constant là dessus vous voulez
réindustrialiser la france chantre du
made in france là dessus on peut se
rejoindre la vraie différence je croire
entre vous et la majorité actuelle c'est
que de l'incantation nous sommes passés
aux actes dans le chômage à 10% qu'il y
avait il ya dix ans et puis quand vous
étiez au gouvernement il est aujourd'hui
à sept et demi pour cent pourquoi selon
moi passage aux actes c'est tout
simplement prendre les mesures qu enfin
il fallait faire pour notre pays
évidemment la compétitivité un
environnement fiscal réglementaire
favorable à l'investissement et à
l'embauché et à l'emploi en à baisser
l'impôt sur les sociétés on a enfin
supprimé une partie des impôts de
production on a enfin supprimé le cic
ans la remplacer par une baisse de
charges en a enfin mis un code du
travail plus favorable à cette
flexisécurité d'un jour 300 voulait
entre vous la question elle est simple
c'est que vous avez dit je crois que la
france est dans la panade pouvez vous
encore dire ça quand nous sommes enfin
parvenus à mettre un niveau de chômage
plus bas qu'il était il ya 15 ans pouvez
vous encore dire que la france est dans
la panade comme nous avons mis en france
un climat d'investissement qui nous
permet de créer de l'emploi industrie à
réponse nous en avons créé je
terminerais là dessus nous en avons créé
500 milles avant la crise nous en avons
créé 250 milles depuis la crise personne
aucune majorité certainement pas là
quand vous étiez au gouvernement ne
l'avait fait alors une réponse brève
moi je suis stupéfait de des éléments de
langage des chiffres de l'insee auto
auto déclamé avec un sourire de
satisfaction monsieur le député il faut
du mérite et sûrement de bras ce que je
vois c'est que on a moins 85 milliards
on est la lanterne rouge de la balance
commerciale les allemands je n'avais lu
ce sens on était à
65,85
l'emploi monsieur montebourg mais je moi
mon sujet et suivant c'est qu'en fait il
manque il ya cinq millions et demi de
chômeurs au bas mot 1 a baissé et il
manque un million d'emplois industriels
pour pouvoir pour pouvoir vivre
correctement avec des bons salaires et
bon salaire cette saison une autre reine
surnommé s'est dit en chine ont bien
d'accord c'est pas des éléments de
langage s'est déroulée pays voisins à
l'espagne 2e aller à l'exception de
l'espagne l'italie son taux quasiment au
plein emploi oui et donc évidemment vous
êtes en train de dire regardez c'est
formidable moi ce que je vois c'est que
tous ces pays sont au blé n'est pas la
grande bretagne mais kubrick cible est
en dessous d'un
industriel monde nous parle de la dette
mais moi je vous parlais dans sa
campagne du déficit commercial qui est
une catastrophe
on importe tout c'est vrai c'est à dire
qu'en fait on ne produit plus rien sur
le territoire à l'autre mercialys est
tout aussi catastrophique quand vous
étiez sauf que nous avons créé de
l'emploi industriel dans ce pays 750
mille emplois industriels créer il y en
a un réseau dit il va quand vous parliez
de formation tout à l'heure une amie à
70 je vais vous dire comment la france
les chairs chevaux usine le plan
marshall de monsieur macron c'est la
destruction tous nos fleurons alstom
techno
elle se crée dans ce pays parce qu'enfin
nous avons fait en sorte les entreprises
peuvent investir peuvent enfin embauchés
dans ce pays ce que vous n'aviez pas
fait vous aviez fait fuir les capitaux
et vous aviez fait fuir justement les
autres ne fait que commencer merci
laurent sa mort
il ya de quoi faire y assemblera tatum
etienne desplanques et passionnant à
propos de déficit commercial on va pas
ouvrir matin parce qu'on va rejoindre
vincent roux au figaro vincent en une
seconde votre questions très précises
comme d'habitude oui c'est sûr les
professeurs le sort des professeurs des
enseignants
la plupart des internautes du figaro
sont favorables à revaloriser le salaire
des profs est-ce que ce l'on joue arnaud
montebourg ça peut permettre de résoudre
la crise actuelle qui est la crise des
vocations pour ce métier j'approuve
l'idée selon laquelle il faut pas
seulement faire un rattrapage mais
rémunérer les professeurs qui font un
métier très difficile
en ayant le souci de la considération de
la nation pour eux ils doivent être
soutenus ils doivent être encouragées
ils doivent être aidés a ajouté que le
salaire est le traitement est très
important donc pour moi c'est un
rattrapage significatif de combien
combien c'était la question il faut il
faut rattraper les onze années de gel
donc on est déjà au dessus de 15 % 15 %
15 % au minimum en fait je vais ajouter
non mais le vrai sujet c'est la ccl
d'outiller les professeurs qui le
demandent même il ne demande pas que des
salaires font dix demandes de la
formation personnes et est peut-être un
changement de méthode de travail en
équipe par exemple voilà vincent merci
infiniment d'avoir posé cette question
soit une réponse plus 15 % d'entrées
quand vous devenez président c'est
fondamental on a quatre services publics
qui vont très mal polis en espagne
deuxième émission je me sentais une
location sinon il faudrait déjà là un
budget le petit le programme d'arnaud
montebourg qui ne comprenaient pas
d'ailleurs cette fameuse proposition
dont on a beaucoup parlé en début
d'émission vous avait clarifié merci
d'avoir été avec nous aujourd'hui dans
audition publique merci monsieur le
député merci monsieur c merci beaucoup
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine bien
sûr 19h30 - en forêt bonne soirée
[Musique]
on se retrouve tous les mercredis à 14
heures pour les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement si le temps fort de la
semaine au sénat avec notre équipe de
journalistes et nos invités en plateau
nous débattrons des sujets qui font
l'actualité du moment à 15h vous suivrez
en